we're now going to look at a method
for approximately or heuristically
solving the nonlinear least squares
problem
there's actually many methods that can
be used so that's a whole world by
itself you can take whole courses on
on this we're going to look at one it's
called levenberg marquardt
we're we actually look at this one for a
couple reasons number one it works
extremely well in practice
and number two it uses actually ideas
that come immediately from this book and
course so all the ideas should be
utterly clear okay so
here's the basic idea and it's a it's a
very general one in
applied math so what we're gonna do
is we want to minimize this
something like that okay so um
now if f here were affined
we would know how to do that that's
least squares we spend
we just spent uh what we spent a lot of
time on that there would be a backslash
involved in your code
okay so so if f4 affine we can solve the
least squares problem but f is not that
fun
so what we're going to do is we're going
to do this we are going to form an
affine approximation of f near the
current point
i should say this is an iterative method
right so we're going to
iterate we're going to take a a point
you know then
uh maybe get a get a better point and
keep going until
we're not making progress okay so okay
um so we're gonna form an affine
approximation now how do you form an
affine approximation of a function
well that's what differential calculus
is literally that is what it is i mean
it's a way for it's a way to in an
organized way
to uh go ahead to to get an affine
approximation of a function that's
really accurate near near a given point
okay and that's the first order taylor
approximation or affine approximation so
we're going to write f hat of x at
z so the semicolon means that the second
argument is special
it's not special it just means it's at
and it's read f hat at z or f hat
near z that's nothing you'd hear people
say okay and that's equal to
f of z the value at that point plus and
then
the this is the deviation the vector
deviation from z
multiplied by the um the derivative
matrix
that's the jacobian or the matrix of
partial derivatives so
that's it um makes perfect sense is the
first order taylor expansion
that's it okay now the idea behind this
is that f hat is of x
is extremely close to f of x provided x
is near z
when x is not near z all bets are off
okay
and in fact that's kind of the
definition of the derivative in
in a sense right um okay
so just bear that in mind that f hat a
little i'll put it another way
to just which is going to come up
momentarily um
f hat of you shouldn't trust f hat
of x semicolon z
if x is too far from z
okay you shouldn't trust it because the
approximation may not be good
okay so that's kind of the uh that
that's the idea
there makes perfect sense and that's
actually the technical term we'll see
later that's used
is trust do i trust my approximation if
x is close to z we really we definitely
trust it now one minor problem is that
calculus is vague on that
what calculus says is when x is near z
and when you ask the crucial question
you know how near they're like i don't
know like near enough
um and they use the concept of a limit
they say that yes it becomes
extremely accurate in the limit of x
going to z um
to be honest in a practical setting that
doesn't help us in the slightest but
whatever well we'll get around that as
well okay
now we're going to do now we're going to
come to the idea and the idea is
you know you don't know how to solve how
to minimize
normal square root of f of x that's your
problem um so we'll do is we're going to
replace
f with an approximation f hat which is
affine
and we do know how to minimize the norm
squared of an affine function that's
called least linear least squares
in this context but outside this context
you just call it least squares
okay oh and by the way that sub problem
we can solve
exactly that's completely non-heuristic
right i didn't have to say it earlier in
the course we were talking about qr
factorization and blah blah blah we're
actually finding
the exact solution these are not your
these were none of those were heuristic
algorithms
we found we found the exact solution
okay so
um so this is the idea uh is
you will form an approach you you can't
solve the problem that you need to solve
so you approximate the problem
essentially by linearizing the function
and then minimizing that or something
like that um
and then we're going to iterate that
that's that's the idea
now there's another objective in this
which i haven't said i mean although
it's kind of implicit here and it's this
that you would like this thing to be
small but you also want
x to be near z and that's that's a
question of trust
right so like if you if x deviates too
far from z
then the approximation may not be good
okay so here's the levenberg marquardt
algorithm it combines these ideas
um then it combined it's just ideas from
the course here it is
um it has iterates x1 x2 x3 so this
superscript
describes the iterates right it's an
iterative algorithm in the sense that it
it um it produces a sequence of these
okay
now iteration k here's what we do um we
first form
the affine approximation of f at at the
current point
right so the current point is sort of
like our best guess now
if k is if the iteration k is now it's
our best guess now of what the solution
is or an approximation of the solution
or something like that so
we have f hat we form this this
approximation that's f hat
and now what we're going to do is this
and it's it's it makes perfect sense
we are going to minimize uh well
the norm squared of the approximation
okay
but we're going to add a secondary
objective and the secondary objective is
super interesting
it says please make this small while
at the same time please don't be too far
from my current xk
now the idea there is very simple
that the closer you are to xk the more
we
trust this approximation trust the
approximation simply means that f hat is
close to f right
it doesn't do you any good to minimize f
hat if f
hat and f are completely wildly
different
uh it doesn't make any difference it
doesn't make any sense at all so that's
the idea
and so lambda actually
is is sometimes referred to lambda k
because it's going to vary with step
size
um that's something that tells you how
far
you know when you trade off the two
objectives right you want to
you want to minimize the norm squared of
the affine
approximation number one um but number
two you don't want to go too far from
where xk
is right not because you don't think the
solution is far away it could be far
away
but that's a that's a question of trust
okay and lambda k essentially gives you
your level of distrust um in the
following
sense that if lambda is super big then
when you solve this
it you're going to get a point that's
very near xk and that means that you
don't trust the model very much at all
or you trust it but only if you're very
close to xk
when lambda gets really small that means
you really trust your model
uh that's what it means and you're going
to find that xk is going to be very far
from xk
okay so this is the idea um
that's the whole thing this is this is
the ludenberg markquart algorithm
oh i haven't told you how to update this
lambda
uh yet but we'll get to that
okay so xk plus 1 is a solution of
a least squares problem and in fact
it's a if you like to say it it's a bi
criterion or by objective
a least squares problem we have a
primary objective
and we have a secondary one and we can
solve that that's
that's just analytically and you get the
solution is this thing
is is this and you'll actually recognize
uh this part as as the general solution
to
a bi-criterion or by objective least
squares problem that we saw when we
studied
that chapter okay so a couple of things
to
mention about it um oh the
solution uh always exists in other words
this thing sorry the inverse always
exists so you can always solve the set
of equations
this thing is invertible um so that's
nice
it doesn't matter or df or anything like
that it just it just it's just
invertible period
that gets invertible if df is zero it's
just fine
um the other interesting thing is the
you have x k
plus one is x k and there's a name for
that that says that x k
is a stationary point of our algorithm
so stationary point means what it sounds
like it means that
if you apply your algorithm to that
point you do a bunch of computation
and then there's a drum roll and you get
back the same points you had before
that's called the stationary point
because if you do it again it's going to
stay there
it's going to always just stay if you
think of the
algorithm iteration as as
as being some kind of a nonlinear
dynamical system then
what this says is it's a it's an
equilibrium point or stationary point of
that dynamical system
okay and to check that you know we would
just say
what would happen if this whole thing
over here were 0 right because that's
what it would mean if x k plus 1 is x k
well this is an invertible matrix so i
can get rid of that and it says that
that's zero and i see oh
df transpose x is zero hey
except for the factor of two which
obviously doesn't matter that's exactly
the condition the stationarity condition
for the problem so
so that says that that if
a point is stationary in ludenburg
marquardt then it says
that the optimality condition holds now
recall that that does not mean
that you know xk is necessarily the
solution
right it means it's a candidate to be a
solution or something like that frankly
no one really
i mean depends on the application people
don't really care about that they just
want to know you know have you found a
good
a good point good point means one with a
small residual
okay and now i'm going to explain how to
update
lambda actually there are many many ways
to do it some are more sophisticated
this is
super duper simple and it's also
extremely intuitive
and it connects to the ideas we have in
the class okay
so if lambda is too big then here's
what's going to happen
your xk plus 1 is going to be too close
to xk
now actually that's fine because it'll
mean the
the affine approximation is very good
but the point is xk is xk plus one is
just a little bit away from
xk right so um and it may take a
very large number of iterations there's
nothing wrong with having lambda
too big it just means you're going to
take a whole lot of iterations
uh to get to a solution or something to
an approximate solution i should say
now um having lambda too small then you
can actually get into trouble
if lambda is too small xk is going to be
it's going to venture too it trusts
the affine approximation too much and
it's going to choose the next point
relatively far from xk now
if you're lucky that's fine um but if
you're unlucky the affine approximation
is poor
and you can even you can even lead to
the case where
in this case uh it would be possible for
the the objective value
at the next at this next iterate to be
higher than the current one
that's not what we call progress okay so
here's the update mechanism
it says if the norm squared that's the
objective
at the k plus one uh iterate is
better that's the strict inequal strict
inequality if it's better than the
current
objective that means you made progress
right and so
you update the new x you accept the new
x and you reduce lambda
and you know you might reduce it by 20
i mean it doesn't matter it just turned
out it just it doesn't matter right but
you know
you reduce it by 20 and the reason is uh
it means it worked but
you kind of want lambda to be as small
as possible that allows you to make
progress
so this you might you might d you'll be
a little bit more aggressive on the next
step that's this
now if if this is false it means
that you found your next point your next
tent at a point
first of all it's not progress because
the objective value went up not down and
so that's something you definitely don't
want so what you do is you don't
update x you just keep it the same value
and what you do is you double lambda and
that means that
you are i mean by the way double it
could be you could multiply by 1.5
3 whatever you like what that means is
if this inequality fails to hold that
means that you did not make progress or
i mean you could even have a go this way
meaning your next point
is worse than your current point if
that's the case it means that you were
too
trusting of your affine model and that
means you need to update
lambda you need to increase lambda
specifically because that'll cause
when you solve that least-squares
problem it'll cause you to be closer to
xk
where we hope the affine model will be
more accurate
so we do that we'll we'll double lambda
uh that's it and we keep the same x so
that's that that's what this looks like
okay um okay so this is uh and now
that's the whole algorithm that's it
i mean you have to give it an initial
point uh you have to give it an initial
value of lambda but other than that
we've told you everything about
about the the thing and this will value
land off and people just take it to be
one something like that so let's look at
an example
it's going to be a range a range
estimation problem
okay so so here it is
u the the minimum
the one that minimizes the norm squared
of f of x and remember that's the sum of
the squares of the residuals to the
ranges right
the blue things by the way show you
where the beacons are which is kind of
interesting so
basically it says you're somewhere um
and you get a noisy measurement of the
distance or range to each of those blue
dots
those are you know beacons or what
doesn't matter
i would this could also be turned around
and these could be individual radar
installations which are giving you range
to a target and now they're coordinating
to try to figure out
where is the target that language
suggests uh not socially positive
applications of this but unfortunately
this is used sometimes for non-socially
positive applications
okay so the contour lines show you the
the um the the set of points where
where f of x norm squared takes a
particular value
red is actually the minimizer and then
you could see
you know all the points in here you know
are are close to
minimum and so on anyway that's it and
here's a graph of it
if you want to see what that looks like
as a function of x now what we're
looking for is that point right there
uh that's this one that's the one that
minimizes this thing
that's going to be kind of our best
estimate of the position
of x now what you'll look at and see is
there's also weird bumps and stuff in
here and it's not
it's it's not it it we'll actually see
momentarily there are some uh
so-called local minimum okay so
um here's the way it works uh and we're
showing
here levenberg marquardt from three
initial points so
here's here's like the first the first
run of ludenburg mark
we start there i mean who who knows why
okay and
the first step takes it here then here
then here then here then here then here
and you can see that it found what we
know is
is actually the the global minimum okay
um
the global minimum means it's it's the
one that actually minimizes the norm
squared of f
okay um here we start this one from here
and it kind of goes along here and then
it it also finds
the global minimum okay this is
interesting
look at this here we started the initial
thing not very far from this other point
where it found the minimum
and this one kind of goes here here here
here here and then it gets stuck there
i mean it finds an okay point but it is
not the actual global minimum of the
problem so
in that case you would say in this case
uh
levenberg marquardt actually solve the
non-linear least squares problem
actually solved it starting from this
point or this point but
not from that point so that that's kind
of the picture
now of course in many dimensions because
we don't really run
you don't need levenberg markward if
it's a function
of two variables right because you just
make a grid and plot it and use your
eyeball
and you i mean you make a plot like that
you find out where the where's the
smallest point
um so the point you know what you really
use this for of course
is for uh cases with you know 10
variables 20
2 000 variables 20 000 variables this is
where you really do it where it goes
without saying you cannot possibly
visualize anything
okay so here
if you look at how the uh the norm
squared of um of
the the objective of what f x k looks
like
um oh and you can see that in these
cases it converges to a number that's
not it's not zero because of the noises
but it's pretty you know it's pretty
small and you can see that in these two
cases the brown trace
and the blue trace um we actually made
it to the global minimum
this red trace we would say this red run
of lemonberg mark
actually got stuck and it got stuck in a
pretty bad
in a pretty bad so-called local minimum
or stationary point
it found one that has a normal square
root of about two
more than two whereas this thing is
really very small i don't know how small
it is
0.1 or something like that and then what
this will show you
is is actually a trajectory of the
this trust parameter lambda k actually
you should call it the distrust
parameter because the larger lambda k
it means the less that you trust your
model and so i think they all started at
0.1
and you can see like in the first case
you can actually work out what happened
right like
so every time it went down it meant that
your last iteration was better than your
current one
every time it goes up by a factor of 2
it means that you were too aggressive
and
went to a point that was too um where
where it actually
you double the lambda right so every
time you do this this goes up if that's
0.1
i don't know what that is 0.13 this is
probably 0.26
right well it's double right and you can
see how this works
uh so this is still all of these parts
here it means that
it means that you met that criterion
which is that you actually
improved uh the objective um
so i should say that over here yeah over
here we're not showing
um those values uh we show them this way
we don't show the tentative values what
we do is
let's find one here between four and
five that's here so what we simply do is
this is it's the same
xk it's x4 is x5
and that simply means that we computed
an x5 or a tentative x5
unfortunately the objective was higher
than where we were so we did not make
progress
and so we didn't accept it and so we
kept the same one that's why this is
level
flat and that's also corresponds to this
jump up because what it does is it what
we do is when
when you have found you've been too
aggressive in updating
uh entrusting your affine model what
happens is you increase
lambda by a factor of two and you keep
the keep the old x